what's up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel today i'm
gonna be reacting to sex as a weapon the
rules of modern dating and understanding
women quote unquote it's complicated
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification bell okay ring it you
already know if you have watched two or
more of my videos and you do not
subscribe me and you we have
beef
beef okay
all right
[Music]
is it easier for a man or a woman to
acquire sex
uh no i think it's kind of equal you
think it's equal okay oh no oh no no no
let me ask you this what is the longest
that a man's ever made you wait for sex
okay so that makes them wait right so
women typically make men wait so isn't
it safe to conclude that it's easier for
women to you know control the sex
you know you know we control it yeah
right in other words women sleep with
who they want men sleep with who they
can right yes okay
so basically if it's harder for a man to
get sex should women be surprised that
guys have lower standards for sex than
women
no but biologically men need it
more than women
who is more likely to influence the
behavior of the opposite sex men or
women men men are you more likely to see
women going to men's night or men going
to ladies nights
for sure
although i
women will go when a game's playing at a
bar
are you more likely to see women going
to men's night or men going to ladies
night
women going to man's night man going to
ladies night
well wouldn't that prove that women are
more likely to influence men's behavior
no women going to
man's night that sticks to my first
question women typical i mean do they
even have men's night
actually they would never invite you to
their man's night does the fact that
ladies nights exist prove that if you
control the women my ex-boyfriend
i don't think he would have
let me go
he didn't really do boys nights but i
don't think he would have been invited
you also control the men
yep
okay so very true okay so women
influence men's behavior i mean do women
do women line up to go to clubs full of
men
no no men line up to go to close to a
woman right okay so then doesn't that
prove that if you control the women you
also control the men you get them to
show up and buy drinks and spend money
so women are more likely to influence
the behavior of men right yeah okay
yeah i guess in that industry okay women
often want to fix or change men's
behavior do you think it's possible to
change men's behavior without first
changing women
[Music]
no no we've just established the press
that's a good question wait so
women have to change in order for men to
change
i guess yeah sort of premise that uh
women influence men's behavior right
yeah so i guess so is it true that men
are [ __ ] because women date [ __ ]
yeah
yeah that's true
guilty the women have the right to come
do women have the right to complain
about men being [ __ ] when they're
enabling that behavior yeah no
why do you say why why because if you're
enabling it then it's stupid that's true
on more problems more shitty men okay is
it easier for a man or woman to acquire
sex
acquire what do you mean is it is it
easier for a man or woman to get sex
it's easier for a woman yeah since it's
harder for men should women be surprised
that guys have lower standards for sex
than women no
do women have the privilege of being
more picky because they have more
options
yeah who regulates the sex in a
relationship the man or the woman
the woman right what's the longest a
man's ever made you wait
i don't wait for [ __ ]
so in order to change men's behavior
don't you first have to change women's
behavior
we try to with uh what's it called uh
you know when the guys dress up naked
with a little thing on their thing
what's called when they're they put on a
show and it's a guy
chippendales exactly that's what we try
to do isn't it true that men are
[ __ ] because women date [ __ ] uh
kinda actually because girls like
i've heard so many guys tell me that i
was nice until i realized women don't
like the nice guy so i became an [ __ ]
i've heard that
so many times so many times
which is like you know physical and also
mental they like well i mean women like
dick but they also like dicks they like
kind of the dicks guys oh dick attitude
not exactly exactly well you guys don't
care about them okay
isn't it true that i
that's so true because
i'm gonna just tell you the psychology
and i'm not saying it makes sense but
i'm just gonna explain it
if you're a guy and
i i've had a guy just be all in on me
like he met me and i was like yeah i
don't drink um at the time like i was
like i don't really go out i'm
kind of i just like work on my youtube
channel i like to travel like that sort
of thing and he was just so a hundred
percent in on me and i was my thought
was like
respectfully why
i'm cool don't get me wrong but like you
barely know me like why are you this
dust like it came across desperate
because i'm like you barely know me and
you're all in so it makes me just think
like one you do this to every single
girl you meet and two it's not like real
like you don't even know me and you
already have these feelings
so
that's why sometimes we prefer the
[ __ ] because
like if a guy is 100 in on you just so
quick it's like
sounds so bad because it is but it's
like like why
like it's just
like don't you want to get to know me
better to decide like why are your
standards just crazy low
that's just how it comes off sorry guys
men are [ __ ] because women date
[ __ ]
yes
so women influence men's behavior do
they have the right to complain about
the way men behave
no
that's not true at all but i mean if if
women influence men's behavior i mean if
guys are nice guys they get friend zoned
so does that explain why guys are
[ __ ] or bad boys because that's what
women respond to
not necessarily i think to each his own
i think women who
look for bad boys they're just bad on
their own and i mean
i mean that's i don't know that's a
tricky question because
it's vice versa i feel like it kind of
feeds off each other the stigma about
when and it feeds off of each other you
look for what you want influence each
other men are supposed to be and if you
complain about a bad boy or a bad girl
then it's your fault because that's what
you're looking for in the beginning why
that's true that's true look at every
situation i've been in with a guy that
like he didn't treat me right i will
genuinely say that [ __ ] was my own fault
that [ __ ] was my own fault i signed up
for it i do not feel bad for me why do
women often choose to make lists of what
they want in a relationship rather than
what they bring to the table
oh that's so true
that's a hard one
um
just like one in that car that has the
fast power the horsepower tinning
windows the top down
but you go in and your credit gets you
the
key in real you know so
that girl's funny
you make that list to hopefully aim it
kia rio is a damn good car i have a kia
rio 06 180 000 miles for the record
still running
why do women often attack a man's
masculinity when they don't get what
they want
because they want to belittle them
why is sex typically the first thing
that's withheld when women don't get
what they want
because that's what it's all about
what does that say about women because
men can be controlled through sex that's
why actually contribute to a
relationship
it depends on the women
isn't that the same thing as using sex
as a weapon against men yes
why do women often attack a man's
masculinity when they don't get what
they want
[Music]
i don't think i'd do that but i'm not
saying i'm not saying you do that but
why do a lot of people or if a lot of
women do it it's to it's because
sometimes men don't like to show their
emotions so they kind of want to see
that man bad cry sort of like come down
from being macho and just i'm a human i
have feelings too
okay why do women want men to show their
emotions when the man's feelings are
typically the last ones considered and
are often made fun of
this [ __ ] make me cry
because we want to know they're there
you know it's like
we got to know you have it
this is so bad but when i think about it
it's like we want to know you guys care
and i think sometimes like when girls
say like they want a guy that's
emotionally available we're like oh we
want we want to see that he cares about
me he loves me
but the problem is
if you get too emotional
and you just it gets to the point where
you're like
kind of a [ __ ]
like we're not we're not attracted to
that
so i don't know what the line is it's
tough because
i don't think the solution is never talk
to your girl about your emotions ever
but
i i think the solution is just tougher
men
in general but we also don't want a
society where men
can't feel like they can talk about
their feelings ever like that's not a
good solution
um
but i don't know the
it's somewhere in the middle
if we ever needed it to show we need to
know that it's there like
why is sex typically the first thing
that's withheld when women don't get
what they want
that's all that men want so what does
that say about what women actually
contribute to a relationship
it says that
we hold the power and we consent the the
sexual acts you know so isn't isn't that
the same thing as using sex as a weapon
against men
it is but we don't have nothing else to
use against them we're not stronger than
them we you know
why is sex typically the first thing
that's withheld when women don't get
what they want manipulation
what does that say about what women
actually contribute to a relationship
i mean
that doesn't mean [ __ ] sex doesn't mean
[ __ ] about what once again if it didn't
mean anything why would be the first
thing that's withheld
manipulation it's just a manipulation
tactic it's the easiest one to bring
forward isn't that the same thing as
using sex as a weapon against men yeah
it's the first thing that we're there
because that's the first thing the man
wants when we first meet a woman we
don't really want to get to know her the
first thing we want we want sex
well what does that say about what women
actually contribute to a relationship
okay
oh that's so funny five percent when we
see a woman
you're not looking like oh it's gonna be
my wife you looking like damn she fine
i'll [ __ ] her
what is the longest you've gone without
having sex
a
month 20 20 years
what is the longest you've gone by
choice without having sex a month so do
jail sentences count
a year
what is the longest by choice by choice
20 years and then two after that without
having sex a year
who is more likely to lie about how long
they've gone without sex men or women
men
don't men lie about getting more and
women lie about getting less yeah yeah
why is that
because it's the it's the stereotypes
that they have against women that you
shouldn't
be having sex a lot who is more likely
to lie about how long they've gone
without sex men or women who's
i don't know they both lie for different
reasons i think men women
don't men lie about getting more and
women lie about getting less yes yeah
why are women who sleep around seen as
[ __ ] while men who sleep around are
seen as stuff because it's easy for
women to get sex like if i
if i really wanted to have sex all i
have to do is go outside find a guy and
be like look i'm in this apartment to
myself
pull up it'd be so easy
on the other hand
men i don't think that's the case
because of the world and the and the
stereotypes it's society and how they
feel like a man who gets more as a
player and a woman who gets more is a
[ __ ]
like a men's value increases in a
woman's value decreases yeah could it be
because it's easy for a woman to be a
[ __ ]
i mean it is easier
could it be because it's easier for a
woman to be a [ __ ]
yeah but we also can get money from it
too
what's the difference between
what's the difference between shaming a
woman for being a [ __ ] and shaming a man
for being an incel
in other words why are women shamed for
having too much sex while men are shamed
for not getting any sex
i guess i don't know men are shamed for
getting sex too
i shame men for getting too much sex
men are shamed but
this is how it is like women will say oh
you're such a player you're this you're
that
but here's the problem here's the issue
women will say that they'll say that but
they'll still sleep with them like
they'll they'll complain that the guy's
hooking up with everyone but they'll
still sleep with the
women have a choice to be a [ __ ] but a
man doesn't have a choice to be an incel
what's in himself involuntarily celibate
okay
like specifically i feel like guys are
shamed when it's more clear that a girl
is not interested and they keep going
for it like when it's too much
why are men shamed for not being able to
get sex but also shame for trying to get
sex
it's all about your approach
i mean isn't that isn't that kind of
damned if you do damned if you don't
like i mean i feel like it is for both
sexes it depends on your approach
sometimes the search is very vulgar
and other men approach like real
gentlemen what are the characters um
that's code for the guys i'm interested
in
basically the hot guy if you're hot
approach me if you're not don't draw six
of a gentleman
um to me is uh not lying about nothing
you know telling them what it is
and whatever they want to do with that
that's what they can do with that what
would you call the female equivalent of
a gentleman
a lady
a lady
what are the characteristics of a lady
respect honor
that's about it should a woman who
doesn't act like a lady expect a man to
act like that's interesting he said
respect honor that's okay guys the more
i've listened to like men's content the
more i've seen that's what men care
about more than anything is just like
being honored and respected
so they'll like a man will overlook a
lot
a lot for a girl if he feels like she
honors and respects him like
he'll over
he'll overlook a past he'll overlook
like
i don't know he'll overlook um
maybe her not being the most attractive
girl he can get like that's that's what
i've noticed like if that girl really is
down for that guy and he he can feel
that like
he'll overlook a lot a lot of the time
no
what is the difference between
respecting a woman and making her feel
special versus the guy just pandering to
her every need
say that one more time what is the
difference between respecting a woman
and making her feel special versus the
guy just pandering to her every need
what is the difference
i'ma give her what she needs not what
she wants
oh that was a good answer good answer
sir
um
does she need her nails done or does she
want her nails done
so she needs them done
i'm gonna do it if she wants them done
i might not
if women weren't slut-shamed and were
actually celebrated for being a [ __ ]
would they still play hard to get
yes why
because you can get more money out of
them if you play hard to get could it be
because women use sex to get power
i do not
to me i don't like accepting big gifts
from men because it's always like what
do you want in return and i don't ever
want to feel like i owe a guy anything
so
i don't know
like
my boyfriend of a year literally offered
me like 20 grand once and i said no
because
i just i don't know i felt weird
accepting that money i don't know
some of them yes yeah are women more
interested in love or power
depends on the person
are men more likely to use power to get
sex or are women more likely to use sex
to get power
sex to get power
do you think women are more interested
in love or power
power
really that's interesting
okay um
if all the men in the world were gay how
would women get power
by
creating and being they would
yeah we'd have to
build [ __ ] basically a dominant
force in society and government and
leadership and influence since men
aren't all gay where will women actually
get their power from
since men aren't all gay where do women
actually get their power from
we said it earlier with the sex
controlling so can we agree that women
get their power by manipulating straight
men
i mean don't win don't women have power
because men give it to them
um
oh my god that's such an interesting
question like what do you mean by power
is he talking about like power in a
relationship that would be true
power
in
congress i would say for sure some of it
like a lot of the
policies
are directed like towards women um
interesting okay oh wait okay
if all the men in the world were gay how
would women get power
she
since men aren't all gay where do women
actually get their power from
they [ __ ]
so can we agree that women get their
power by manipulating straight men
it depends on the individual but yeah
okay don't women get power by using sex
as a weapon against men
don't women get power because men give
it to them
women are the world women women women
have power
only most men only want to take the
power because they want to take from
from women if god was a man a woman or
animal and walked up to me i'm gonna go
to the woman because i believe god is
god as a woman so i'm the wrong person
next that quest
okay we got power regardless well right
we can't be born without a woman well
right but women can't conceive without a
man
right that's true but did did don't
y'all read the bible and the bible say
that uh the virgin mary had a time yeah
but that's what she no
she had a child without a man
what power but that happened one time
has it ever happened again since then
they said that a snake talked to adam
and eve oh my god
sir i think you're losing i think you're
losing the point of the question i ain't
seen a snake talk since i've been alive
so at the end of the day men give women
their power right so aren't women
fighting the hand that feeds them when
they say men are toxic man ain't [ __ ]
damn
damn that was a good point
definitely
is that smart i mean are the women
smarter if they're doing that
no it's not smart but it's sort of like
a dog it's like dogs are messy dogs make
you know a lot of noise but at the same
time everybody wants them it's they
still that cute cuddly moment so it's
same with men and finally what advice
would you give to the men that don't
trust women
you don't trust yourself
and you need the star trek okay
people are shitty on both sides men lie
to women and women lied to mad it goes
it goes both ways yourself so you can
trust her
because not all women are bad
um okay that was really interesting i'm
gonna have to react to this more okay
guys
you already know do not forget to
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification bell let me know what video
i should react to next time in the
comments follow my instagram just dot
pearly things and i will talk to you
guys next time